c'est un retour définitif en Colombie
pour Ingrid Bettencourt ses enfants qui
vivent en France sont adultes et ont
moins besoin d'elle je crois que la
salle véritable force qui explique un
retour après tout ce que nous avons vécu
c'est un amour pour la Colombie qui est
essentiel dans mon cas et je comprends
très bien que mes enfants ne partagent
pas ça mais pour moi c'est
voilà j'ai un immense bonheur à être ici
6 ans et demi de captivité aux mains des
phares ou allant durer les pires
souffrances en compagnie de centaines
d'autres otages de la guérilla un
martyre qu'elle raconte de façon
magistrale dans son livre même le
silence à une fin ces images de 2007 où
on la croyait sur le point de mourir ont
suscité la sympathie et l'indignation du
monde entier se traduisant par des
manifestations en Colombie et en
particulier en France où le gouvernement
a tout fait pour obtenir sa libération
il y a pas de problème pour nous
elle est vivante
c'est une opération spectaculaire de
l'armée colombienne qui l'a finalement
libéré en même temps que trois otages
américains je suis colombienne mais je
suis française mon cœur est partagé elle
est reçu en héroïne abogota par le
président Alvaro
le président Sarkozy lui décerne la
Légion d'honneur
avec ma famille donc très important pour
moi de me reconstruire psychologiquement
de sortir de cette
ce qui a été le contrecoup de la jungle
et puis de reconstruire ma famille et ça
a été ma priorité 14 ans plus tard
psychologiquement comment se
porte-t-elle les cicatrices sont là
c'est une période de ma vie que j'ai
jamais oublié que je porterai toujours
mais j'ai réussi véritablement à sortir
le meilleur de toutes ces années c'est à
dire me dire bon j'ai quand même appris
beaucoup de choses sur l'être humain sur
ma capacité de résistance sur
des priorités de la vie la possibilité
de voir le monde d'une autre façon
je n'aurais évidemment pas voulu vivre
ce que j'ai vécu mais je pense que dans
la vie il faut construire à partir de
tout ça
la Colombie a signé la paix avec les
phares en 2016 elle a appuyé tout le
processus et confronté ses ravisseurs
pour la Colombie ça a été un moment
extraordinaire et moi j'ai été à fond
avec le processus de paix je pense que
ça a été la meilleure des solutions pour
la Colombie évidemment il y a des choses
qui doivent être faites par exemple la
réparation des victimes par exemple le
fait que les victimes connaissent la
vérité de beaucoup de choses il y a une
vérité juridique mais c'est pas
suffisant moi comme victime j'ai accepté
par exemple que mes ravisseurs n'avaient
pas en prison contre le fait de
aller en justice donner toute la vérité
accepter les crimes et évidemment rendre
les armes se démobiliser c'est quand
même énorme
la Colombie ne va pas bien elle le sait
aujourd'hui nous avons 22 millions de
colombiens qui qui sont dans une
situation économique très précaire dont
7 millions qui sont
au bord de la famille
très très grave pour la Colombie donc on
a besoin de changer le système et c'est
il faut arrêter la corruption il faut
qu'on arrête il faut véritablement nous
n'avons
plus de solutions
[Musique]
le fléau numéro 1 c'est la corruption
je l'ai dit depuis 30 ans c'est le fléau
du pays il y a 30 ans nous avions déjà
dépoussé de corruption forte parce que
c'était le processus ocho 1000 on venait
de sortir de la crise de son père avec
le financement par le cartel de Cali ça
a ouvert une porte ou finalement comme
il y a une totale affinité
il y a eu cette espèce de sensation
qu'en fait on pouvait tout faire et ils
ont tout fait les paramilitaires sont
rentrés les trafiquants drogues sont
rentrés
tout a été
toutes les instances de corruption là où
il est beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
illégal sans rentrer dans la politique
le carburant de cette corruption c'est
le narcotrafic la Colombie produit 75%
de la cocaïne du monde il y a 4 ans
c'était 50% de toute façon quand on
parle de la Colombie tout s'imprique et
tout passe par le problème de la droite
que ce soit la corruption que ce soit
les problèmes de sécurité et la violence
l'environnement l'Amazonie est en feu le
déboisement n'est accéléré et ça c'est
vraiment le trafic de la drogue donc
partout où les dégâts moraux mais de
patrimoniaux aussi pour la Colombie
c'est énorme Ingrid Bettencourt est en
train de relancer le Parti vert oxygène
qu'elle avait fondé en 1998 avant sa
capture par la guérilla elle a
l'intention de le placer en opposition
farouche au nouveau président de gauche
Gustavo Petro soupe
pour l'avenir de la Colombie malgré tout
ce qui se passe moi je pense qu'on va
s'en sortir
[Musique]